voilà francis lalanne donc ça s'appelle
à mon ami le kanak voilà ce qui vous
arrive quand vous est sifflée sur un
terrain de foot français n'ont pas
besoin de ce havre et tu sais quoi
aller où
c'est quoi
haye avait lui déjà repartir céline dion
comment ça s'est passé virale et bien
les à bloc et elle est au juste pour moi
passer la baisse de francis
gillot n'ont pas voir ce que ça donnera
benoît vous n'avez pas fait l'émission
de laurent boyer vous qui avez tout fait
pour le lancement du boulet est calé
alors que tu en penses
style garou
40 m'accepter drôle tu as des saillies
qui sent vraiment pas ce que disait
damco en lice bon je vous laisse je vais
retrouver michaël youn tu reviens pour
le top sur la planète à tout à l'heure
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous émettez un
pouce bleus